our first video about californium 14
years ago
was very short
quite a few military applications
usually involving the word nuclear but
now
we know a lot more about californium
we've learnt quite a bit brady has
visited
the place
oak ridge national lab where they
manufacture california so we can tell
you a lot more
to begin with california was first
detected in 1950
in a cyclotron where
alpha particles were accelerated against
the target and a few thousand atoms were
detected then in the 1960s
oak ridge national lab
built a new type of reactor that had a
very intense
flux very intense beam
of neutrons
and those neutrons could
build up new elements from uranium
brady went and saw how they put
small pellets into aluminium
and this is irradiated in the reactor
and then after the irradiation you can
extract the elements that have been
formed and californium element number 98
is really the last element in the
periodic table where you can isolate
enough of the element to see
either its compound or the metal itself
brady was shown some samples of
californium
when he was in the lab
in
oak ridge and this is california 249
in a liquid form this is very dosey
again this is another very hot sample
we have consolidated this from
multiple
legacy samples they're both californium
they're both californian solutions
the one on the left is a little more
concentrated you can see some green
color to it the one on the right is a
much lighter green
that container
that she's putting it into is a tungsten
it's a polymer tungsten container so it
both shields from the gamma and neutrons
this is a californium 251 mixture
this starts out as 252 that has decayed
for over 30 years
so it now is a 30 percent 35 percent
californian 251 the rest is california
250 and 249. so it's brown from the rad
damage or the radiation damage
and there's a only
about two milligrams of material in
there and it's should be a whitish
powder it's a nitrate solid
californium nitrate solid this material
with the high californian 251 content
is what we will be making target
segments out of in order to go to dubna
for their next super heavy element
accelerated experiment we could possibly
get element 119 or 120 depending on what
projectile they use but we're in the
process now of recovering this material
and cleaning it up from old californian
sources so we hope to by spring be
starting to deposit this electro deposit
it on the sources on the
target material the point about this
element
is that it is
very radioactive it has a number of
different isotopes which are relatively
long-lived two years or even longer
and you have to realize because there
are so many atoms
even in a small particle of one of these
elements
that you can get intense radiation
coming out
without
losing all your sample immediately so
even a few
micrograms can produce quite intense
neutron beams and these neutrons are
used for all sorts of applications
imaging cracks in materials and so on
but i just want to focus on two
uses of californium
one of them
is to make the element a ganeshan
the heaviest element in the periodic
table which was synthesized in dubna in
russia
and
there they used the target that was
coated with a thin layer of californium
and bombard it with accelerated nuclei
of calcium 48.
you can see we have a nice video about
calcium 48 and
these two elements
calcium 48
and californium
fused together
element 20 plus element 98 gives you
element 118
so
it is a really relatively efficient way
of
synthesizing these super heavy elements
so this is actually the fin tubing that
we start with to make these target rods
when we go to load them
in the actual cubicle space that you're
looking at they've been machined down to
just these fins
which is impressive since this material
is extremely soft and my 10 year old
daughter could bend it into a pretzel so
to get these fins exactly the way we
need them to be put into the reactor
is a feat in itself for machining what
you don't see are the pellets 31 of them
that are made of this size
but are gray but this is what's made of
the curium oxide blended with aluminum
pressed
and then loaded into this tubing
final weld is done remotely and the last
thing that we're going to do is put that
shroud on and clamp it
over these fins to stay in place
to direct the pool water from that high
flex isotope reactor directly over the
tube itself
after this it does its final checks
and then all of them we have five
targets total in this campaign
we'll get cleaned
and then we're going to load them into a
25 ton shielded container
and then that container will be moved
outside and gets put on a truck and we
move it 700 feet over to that high flex
isotope reactor
once it lands there they in turn will
put it into their storage pool suspend
it under water and unload these targets
one at a time with long pull handle
tools
they will hold them in a storage rack
until they're ready to be loaded into
what's called the flux trap the flux
trap is the dead center of the fuel
element and that's where your maximum
neutron flux if you can imagine this 2.5
times 10 to the 15 neutrons per
centimeter squared per second so
basically a billion million or a million
billion however you want to look at it
neutrons in a very small area per second
we will leave these targets in the
reactor for about four cycles a cycle is
23 to 24 days
so nearly 100 days
exactly so you want to do the math you
got to take that 100 days time 24 hours
times 60 minutes times 60 seconds times
that 2.5 times the 15. i've never done
it
but that's how many neutrons these
targets are going to see we want those
neutrons to interact with those curium
isotopes and an isotope is the same
element different number of neutrons so
we want to add more neutrons push it
along and then when it gets too many
neutrons it's either going to have a
reaction that splits apart or
it emits a beta particle and creates a
proton and we get the next element so
that's how we can go from curium to
berkelium to california to einsteinium
and eventually fermium so after a
hundred days
what's inside the tube
so you still have those oxide pellets
but what and it's going to look the same
but from a radiochemistry point of view
you have basically transmutated you've
changed those curium isotopes either
into fission products or into higher
actinide isotopes so again the berkelium
einsteinium californium fermium so of of
this cocktail of amazing elements that's
now inside the tube
what do you most want what do you want
to get out and what's rubbish
so we want the actinides we want to
recycle the curium because only about 15
of that has been changed we want to
recycle it for the next set
we definitely want the berkelium the
einsteinium and the fermium those are
being used for both nuclear physics and
chemistry research
but specifically we want the industrial
isotope the californium 252 because
that's the one that's why we do this
the other stuff that we don't want are
the fission products which are
lanthanides those will go out as a waste
product so after the targets have been
irradiated we'll let them decay for 90
days to for the iodine 131 we just don't
want to handle it here and they come
back in that same 25 ton shielded
container and we're going to start in
cubicle seven that's where we start the
radiochemical processing they can just
be lowered down into this cubicle and in
the dead center of the floor there's a
round plate with lots of tubing going
down into it
that is the cover for the dissolver tank
everything gets dissolved the target
tubing gets dissolved the coolant shroud
gets dissolved the pellets themselves
because they were an aluminum matrix as
well
so the caustic solution
it will only dissolve the aluminum
everything else is left as a solid and
it's captured on a filter it's a sodium
hydroxide heated to 90 degrees celsius
so a hot basic solution to get rid of it
so that's the aluminum will go out as a
waste stream the solids are caught on
that filter so we'll have to rinse them
off and dissolve them from a solid into
a solution what's that like it's like a
big gray mush
to be honest i've never seen it
so i'm not sure
if that's what i think of i think it's
like a brillo pad is what's capturing a
very fine mesh to capture those fines
and you take that and you're going to
rinse it in a acid solution of nitric
acid then that solution in turn we will
start trying to clean up anything we can
off of it
but then we have to take that solution
and convert it into
hydrochloric acid so you went from
nitric to hydrochloric
so we're creating more volume but the
reason we have to do that is we have to
separate the product we want the
actinides from the product we don't want
with the lanthanides and if you remember
anything about your chemistry in the
periodic table those are those bottom
two rows by themselves but their
chemistry is extremely similar
so the process we use is called lithium
chloride and on exchange and it was
developed by a scientist
greg chopin out of florida state
university
we still use it today and it's over 60
years old so we do that over here in
cubicle 6.
and it may be hard to see but behind
this manipulator in the back right is a
silver column and that's where it's
loaded and it allows us to separate
those lanthanides they will go out as
their own waste stream
and believe it or not the next
cut we can do is that recycled curium so
we're going to capture that carium hold
it in solution
and then what's remaining will wash off
will be those actinides
that actinide solution gets converted
back into a nitric acid form so you can
see the conversions back and forth a lot
and all this is being done remotely in
these hot cells
but those actinides that actinide
product we're going to send it down to
cubicle 4. when we talk about doing
transfers what you don't see below the
floor of the cubicle are actual we have
tanks
and we have a lot of connections and
that's what you're seeing with this
tubing it allows us to move the
solutions between these different tanks
along the whole hot cell bank
as like i mentioned earlier this
facility was built and went operational
in 1966 over 50 years ago we are still
able to use that capability that was
designed
50 plus years ago same idea there's a
very tall column in the back right
corner it's a much narrower column
again a four foot tall column
and it's got ion exchange media on there
and the processing is called alpha
hydroxy isobutyric acid or ahib
again a methodology that was done by one
of the pioneers darlene hoffman in the
1960s and that allows us to actually
separate out those actinide products but
they come out reverse
so the fermium if that was produced and
we would only be producing at picogram
levels or less it's element 100 it would
come off first then einsteinium and
element 99 then the california 98
berkeley 97
and the reason being is the atomic radii
of those heavier elements is actually
smaller
and the this process allows us through
changing the ph
chemically we have changes but also
we're changing the characteristics of
the resin
it has to be this tall because you need
all that length and time to start from a
solution that looks like this to
separate those bands elementally as
they're coming down
we have detection capability in the hot
cell to look for alpha particles and
neutron particles so we can tell along
the column as well as as it's coming out
in the drips
what we're looking at once the products
come off
now they may go in different directions
the berkelian which we've heard so much
about that's been used for the
discoveries of element 117 and 115
it has about a 310 day half-life but the
berkelium is so close to the californium
also berkeley and 249 decays to
californium 249. so we want to separate
as much of that californium
from the berkeley and we actually do
that with a solvent extraction process
in this same cubicle
our hot cell guys are so good they can
separate it out where we have less than
a microgram quantity of total california
then it will go upstairs to our glovebox
lab for that final purification where it
was below a nanogram for california so
that goes through a lot of stages so
that's your berkeley of separation so
the californian 252 which is actually
the program that does the bulk of this
work
californium-252 is unique in that it has
a 2.6 year half-life
and then when it does decay
three percent of the time it's just
gonna fission it's gonna split apart and
when it does it gives off neutrons
very similar in energy and number to
that of uranium-235
so it's a thermal neutron source
and the biggest application of that is
analyzers the coal cement and mineral
analyzers use it literally as the
materials coming out of the ground but
also as it's going through the
purification process
looking for those impurities the
neutrons will activate the impurities
those impurities will give off gamma
signals and then the operators will know
which way to move the material
bigger neutron sources are used for
things like nuclear fuel the uranium-235
looking to ensure that there's
uniformity along those 14 foot long fuel
rods
and also any new nuclear reactor as well
as one that's been offline for any
significant time
needs a startup source and california
252 is ideal for that application these
final products these are isotopes that
they're shipping out of here scientists
or researchers or whoever wants them
what form are they in are they like a
few grains of powder are they normally
in a solution what does it look like
when they leave here so for the
einsteinium the berkelium and even tiny
like california 249 quantities they're
going to be most likely in a dried
nitric form so they were in a nitric
acid and we just dry it down and in kind
of a cone-shaped vial
and it's just going to look like a light
powder that's it most likely like a
lightish yellow or green color
but when we do californium-252 as we
ship as a bulk quantity to industrial
partners who make the sources it's
actually a wire back when this was in
its heyday in the 70s and 80s and early
90s
its focus was all research
the berkeley and the einsteinium and
fermium mass quantities compared to what
we did today the californium was just
oops we made it along the way what can
we do with it
now it's completely shift where the
driver is the california 252 market and
then we harvest the other isotopes
because they are made along the way as
well even though we've done it 78 times
and we have a good idea of what we're
doing
there's something unique every time in
different areas of the processing all
the way to when we make the wire next
door
it's never the same twice there's always
something we've got to work through and
understand
there's always something upset with the
chemistry so i still consider this an
art and science more than a production
activity
so with so much effort to produce such
tiny quantities you might be wondering
what californium 252 is worth
a figure widely quoted is 27 million
dollars per gram now i couldn't find
anyone to confirm that for me
this paper way back from 1999 revealed
the cost to be
60
per microgram that's 60 million dollars
per gram at a time when the same mass of
gold was worth about 10 bucks
of course no one buys a whole gram of
californium-252 only the tiniest amounts
are produced each year most of it here
at oak ridge
and a smaller amount over here
in russia
and that brings us
to the
new paper which describes making a
chemical compound
of californium over the years people
have done quite a lot of chemistry with
californium making chlorides oxides and
so on
but
this paper describes
doing so-called organometallic chemistry
where you form metal carbon bonds
so they had an iron of californium
and put on
rings containing five carbons
onto the
californium and what makes this
chemistry interesting
is that
they not only manipulated the chemicals
to synthesize the compound
but they could grow crystals that were
big enough
for you to see and they're a really nice
deep ruby red color
the actual chemistry is done in large
glove boxes but
because of the elements radioactivity
the person working on it is surrounded
by a tape rather like a police barrier
to crime scene
to stop other people coming into this
area of higher radioactivity is this
compound on borrowed time because all
the californium's destined to sort of
fall apart and collapse and
and in quite an energetic way
well the compound will decompose over
time because the half-life of
californium i think the isotope they
used was only a small number of years
but
the radiation was not intense enough to
destroy the crystal and what they did in
this research was not only to make the
californium compound
but to make
other compounds that were related
californium is below
dysprosium in the periodic table so they
made the dysprosium compound
the dysprosium compound is colorless
the californian one is red so they did
calculations to try and explain what was
the origin of the difference in colors
the origin lies in the way that the
electron levels
occur in these different molecules they
also look to the americium compound
and gadolinium and one or two others as
well what is really important
is that they demonstrated that even with
these
relatively small amounts
of compounds milligram quantities of
compounds you can do an awful lot of
chemistry presumably this californium
compound will never serve any purpose
it's just to
further our knowledge of what's possible
i think
of course no compound of which you can
make such small quantities is ever going
to be very useful
but
it can help us as you say in increasing
our understanding of how these elements
react they can help us refine
our computational techniques for
computing the properties of these
compounds
and
it also helps us to manipulate or learn
how to manipulate small
quantities of very dangerous compounds
well you made it this far maybe you'd
like to support our endeavors on patreon
get your name next to an element on our
periodic table of patrons
no one's claimed californium yet
although you might prefer something a
bit more well-known higher up the table
details are in the video description and
they lost my clearance
between oak ridge and los alamos so i
missed being a co-discoverer of
einsteinium and fermium and i've never
ever gotten over it